- [male] (laughs) Well,
you asked for this.
(rock music)
Told you. Breathe.
- I like Halloween. I like dressing up.
I'm bad at planning.
I need her to have the initiative
and then she holds the whip and says,
"This is what you're gonna wear."
- I don't have a whip.
- When I was younger I never was able
to get a Halloween costume.
My dad would always give me
the Nigerian clothes.
"Oh, you're a Nigerian
prince for Halloween."
Didn't even get me a crown.
- I'm definitely not like
into the whole costume thing.
- The only costume Steve's
ever worn was last year.
I was Minnie Mouse and I bribed him
into being Dead Mickey Mouse.
- I think it frustrates you
a little bit that I like
don't like ...
- Well I get so into it. Maybe
after this he'll be inspired.
(fun string music)
- I chose Abraham Lincoln.
You don't often see
black Abraham Lincolns.
You don't often see buff Abraham Lincolns.
And you don't often see Abraham Lincolns
with like giant ass glasses.
I like my costumes to be
a little bit historical,
educational.
- I chose Han Solo.
Just because I feel like
Tyler looks great in a vest.
There's something about
Tyler that's the like,
the classic Harrison Ford-type man
where like he doesn't like
to ask for directions.
- I chose Zoolander for Steven.
I've seen it too many times.
This is my sly way of trying to get him
to do a couple's costume with me because
I was thinking about being Hansel.
(bright fun music)
- I have no clue what she
could have possibly picked out for me.
Her, like, reference point is so old.
- My guess is Star Wars.
She knows that I love Star Wars.
I like Han because he's a
maverick and he's a little rogue.
If she gives me Luke,
says something about me.
- You mentioned that it's really cool
and that you would wear
the thing you picked for me.
- Right.
- She keeps telling me that
she picked Barbie for me,
which I know it's not that.
This could be great and
this could be catastrophic.
- This guy even looks like me.
- Oh, my god. Yeah, of course.
- Yep. This seems about right.
Halloween, you can be anyone you
could ever imagine, she went with
Abraham Lincoln.
- Han Solo's the greatest.
I said one time that I
wish that I was Han Solo
but I'm probably more of a Luke,
and now I feel like I've
graduated to Han Solo.
- I don't know if I
can pull off Zoolander.
- Maybe she's into dudes in big hats.
- If my girlfriend thinks
that I'm like a space cowboy,
I mean that's pretty awesome.
- Blue Steel, it's like uh,
F***, I can't do it.
S***, this is going to
be harder than I thought.
(bright fun music)
- The thing I like about this
costume is, it's a two for one
You put it all on and
you're Abraham Lincoln,
or you can just throw this on
and you're just Chippendale's.
(beatboxes)
- I definitely feel more like Han Solo
right now that I'm putting on the vest.
- It just feels weird. It feels weird.
Like even for Halloween.
- Now you can't tell
that the guns are out,
and I'm Abe Lincoln.
- This is not the Han Solo gun,
and I know this because I
have the actual Han Solo gun.
- One man, one beard, one dream.
- This is going to scare me away
from trying more costumes (laughing).
- Mmmm (in funny voice) this
is how I assume he talked.
(bell dings)
(upbeat music)
- He looks great!
You look hot, babe.
- (laughs) You look so ...
- (laughs)
- Four scores and seven years ago.
Take a bologna and put
it in a ham sandwich,
I'm Abraham Lincoln.
- Yes.
- I think I'm nailing
the space cowboy look.
And I think it fits me.
- I mean the vest.
- This is exactly what I wanted.
- (laughing)
- What is this, a center for ants?
- (laughing) I'm gonna cry.
- Right here I'm Abraham Lincoln.
Boom. Right now I'm Magic Mike.
(beatboxes)
- Okay.
- Tyler Williams, space cowboy.
I think I'm going to put
that on my business card.
- Settle down. Settle down.
- Yeah, just a preview.
- This is super trendy right now.
- Babe, you've never looked better.
- You should wear this out.
(acoustic guitar)
- Steve looks great and
we're gonna look even better
when we go out as Zoolander and Hansel.
- I am more confused ...
- (laughs)
- now, than I've ever
been in my entire life.
- I feel like I opened this side of Tyler
that I'm not sure I should have opened.
- It was always there.
Say that you love me.
- No. I'm not doing it. I
know what you're gonna do.
- Try, I just want to see what happens.
- (sighs) I love you.
- I know.
- Goddamn it.
- (laughs)
- You're glowing.
- He's cute enough to
be on a postage stamp.
I knew you were gonna
put your own spin on it.